tu as lu que vous avez ce qu'il ya de
plus intéressant dans un spectacle c'est
les impros et comme dans mon spectacle
je suis en permanence avec les
spectateurs et bien forcément des impros
il y en a plein il n'y a pas de
spectacle qui se ressemblent alors
aujourd'hui vous allez voir une
compilation des moments qui n'aurait pas
dû arriver dans ce spectacle mais que je
filme parce qu'à chaque fois j'ai une
caméra mois poser sur la sienne pour
pouvoir bosser
une fois que vous avez partagé ça vous
avez aimé apparent parce que la vidéo
elle a fait 6 ans vues donc je me suis
dit ok épisode 2 avec les inédits du
spectacle et comme la dernière fois
l'eau et qui m'a dit ah ouais mais ça tu
le fais tout seul et où je fais ya pas
de problème j'ai mis la caméra j'ai fait
les réglages et pas un petit set up toi
un peu fou c'est toi qu'a fait tout cela
toute la lumière tous et hop tout
l'accueil et de la première vidéo
ah ouais j'ai pas dis pour celle ci loïc
génériques
vous allez voir 50 pro2 que j'avais
diffusée sur instagram deux qui sont
100% inédite et une très longue qui
s'est passé à la télévision
c'est gênant voilà mais c'est passé pas
aussi gênante que le mec bourré que vous
verrez aussi tout à l'heure on commence
sur une date de singularité à
onet-le-château où je sais pas pourquoi
on a parlé de balkany dans quelle ville
habite patrice le gers
bennis et le monde qu'est ce qui va
quitter un peu à bout un mois peut-être
face de balkaniser un peu avoue ça
suffit d'affaires belkadi un peu y a pas
besoin d'être mentaliste pense avoir
depuis dix ans que quand utiliser la
maison pamplemousse et pa nou lé pa nou
quand même j'ai vu juste après le
jugement alors reconnu que c'était à
elle
oui une fois qu'elle a été puni c'est
juste après elle a dit oui c'est vrai
qu'on lit ni mais quand même c'est parce
que depuis dix ans vous disiez que
c'était pas vous dire qui n'a jamais
essayé de fraude est un petit peu ça me
rappelle d'affaires kalisa qui disait je
n'ai pas de contentieux
tous sont égaux leahy l'a fait ah oui
oui mais est-ce qu'on pourrait pas
instaurer un truc de tu joues tu perds
tu n'as que jusqu'au bout ils peuvent
nier
par contre ils sont gaulle et ils
prennent double tête il avouerait avant
voilà je sais pas pourquoi j'avais parlé
de ça mais ça m'a fait beaucoup rire
dans les commentaires une note de aa à
10 sur la règle de mon nouveau jeu je
vous écoute la prochaine vente c'était à
serris essais à un spectateur qui est
clairement panique et ça dure pas
longtemps mais ça me fait pas mal rires
c'est parti et c'est ça aussi le biais
cognitif seller penser qu'on a alors
qu'à la base on voulait pas les avoir on
n'en n'était pas sûre je vous dis penser
un outil une couleur et la majorité des
gens pensent au marteau rouge
ils savent pas pourquoi mais parce que
le rouge est imprégné notre vie dans les
choses importantes
le sang l'interdiction la correction à
l'école et ça marche aussi par exemple
avec les signes astrologiques moi je
suis scorpions comme toi des films mais
les scorpions on dit toujours qu'on est
très meester et le très intelligent
alors moi depuis que je suis petit je
crois pas du tout astrologique pas une
seconde mais je me dis je suis
mystérieux intelligent si le personnes
croient sur l'astrologie mais tout le
monde a vu son signe au point de s'en
imprégner on va en fait une expérience
un truc très rapide et bien rigolo votre
prénom monsieur c'est vous monsieur
sagittaire sont merveilleux
la neige tout quand même je te prends un
match ça va être intéressant je suis
cool biz
passons maintenant aux inédits ce que je
n'ai jamais diffusé donc en plus ce sera
en plein écran plus agréable pour vous
c'est pas encore le mec bourré ça ce
sera juste après c'est mal
maël c'est un spectateur que j'ai eu sur
l'île de saint martin moselle j'ai joué
à saint martin donc dans les caraïbes
j'ai jeté trois représentations là-bas
et emma elle était présent ainsi que son
père une famille passionnante
le v6 te demander à quelqu'un de
récupérer les cartes
j'ai mélangé de me les rendre quand vous
avez une carte en tête vous levez la
main que il ou elle puisse vous
identifier donc une personne qui
ramassent tout l'écart qui les mélanges
me les rend ces partis et attend sa
toute une génération mais ça me va
ok tu y as tu fait
[Applaudissements]
j'ai programmé le père c'est le fils qui
se lève j'ai jamais eu ça dans ta vie
c'est énorme c'est incroyable oh mon
dieu c'est énorme
là bas tu as des gens fassent usage vous
débrouillez vous fait le show télé
mélange un peu tu me les rend beaucoup
applaudir bamako gâchis par la foire 1,7
pour le rôle
merci mon fait merci beaucoup merci à
toi
il a tapé là n'avait alors je n'en
mettrai plus du spectacle mais sache que
comme tu me plais beaucoup dans ton
énergie à la toute fin du spectacle qui
prendra la décision la plus importante
du spectacle alors te mets pas la
pression mais pas aussi j'ai pas fixé
d'entraînement tout à leur excuse moi
maël ces bons tac tac tac
non c'est bon jeu j'avais une meilleure
image mais vous fait penser à des
grosses mamelles de ben ok peut taper
mamelles du creusot
est-ce que je peux a organisé une soirée
vous faites venir que votre famille mais
c'est moi qui vous regarde
la prochaine c'est également sur l'île
de saint-martin s'est également and i
lady et oui c'est le mec bourré enfin
c'est yvan je sais pas s'il est bourré
ou s'il est tombé dedans quand il était
trop petit c'est possible aussi mais ça
a été un des moments les plus drôles que
j'ai public sur scène bref vous allez
regarder ça vous pouvez laisser un
laïcat cette vidéo pour du soutien
d'ailleurs l'oit là il me semble qu'il y
en a qui ne sont pas abonnés à la chaîne
alors qu'ils regardent la chaîne est ce
qu'on leur laisserait pas trois secondes
dans sa bonne est comme ça c est abonné
vous maintenant activé la cloche
si vous êtes déjà abonné aussi vous
pourrez activer la cloche ouais c'est
important de ce qu'on voit dans les
stades qu'une personne sur deux peut à
beaune est donc abonnée vous c'est bon
c'est parti hé bé oui eh ben oui eh bien
c'est parti
tu veux participer toi c'est quoi ton
prénom yvan à ok eh ben il va galérer
mois apparemment ok j'en ai 5 g de
l'oxygène et de l'hydrogène je crois qui
vend ses d'éthanol
4 c'est ton dernier mot [ __ ]
deux trois quatre chefs de l'univers
bien ici via la viola
jeanne a tué le chef de l'univers il
vend on est tous mourir un trou noir
hockey autant de toi autant le toit
c'est un secteur
c'était plus
alors tu vas
j'ai bien connu autour de toi ça dépend
ok c'est pas faux voilà super ça veut
dire qu'à regarder d'arbres et toi tu
seras la clémence oui oui oui un seul
scotch pour toi c'est clair hier il a
des boues ou pas je vous propose d'en
débattre dans les commentaires mais
d'après moi le débat va vite tourner en
alors le dernier c'est mon plus
incroyables moments de scène ça a été
diffusée très récemment en prime time
sur ces huit c'était sur les bio de
l'impossible de jérémy ferrari
donc nous on risque d'avoir la vidéo qui
va être démonétisé ça c'est pas grave
mais surtout qui bat strike et qu'on va
pas pouvoir voir s'ils font une
réclamation pour les droits d'auteur du
coup mon char loïc peux-tu des tares qui
auraient un petit peu cette image peu tu
toi peut-être inverser les trucs changer
la mettre dans une télé tu vois on va
faire un truc comme ça donc donc l'image
a pas être folle folle mais le contenu
va être passionnant c'est le moment le
plus dur pour moi de sur scène de toute
ma vie
forcément il faut que ce soit en plus en
prime time sur ces 8 sur une grosse
émission comme ça avec plein de gros
humoristes alors c'est drôle du coup
parce que j'essaye de faire des vannes
en impro dessus par contre le problème
c'est de réussir à faire du mentalisme à
ce moment là je vous laisse regarder ça
et je vous retrouve à la fin c'est parti
petite astuce de loïc henry je pense
qu'elle était juste très timide d'être
sur scène impressionner ou alors qu'elle
avait pris un truc aussi un c'est
possible ou alors un subtil mélange des
deux mais on a passé un bon moment si la
vidéo est diffusée aujourd'hui c'est
qu'elle a donnée son droit à l'image et
que celle là fait marrer il n'y a pas eu
de problème en fait c'est jamais dans la
moquerie ça se passe toujours bien avec
tout le monde pour le spectacle sache
aussi qu'à la fin de chaque spectacle et
c'est le cas depuis dix ans je suis en
dédicace à la fin et on se rend compte
les dates de tournée c'est ça
c'est toute cette carte là vous pouvez
aller sur le site est un moteur de
recherche comme ça et là c'est les
prochaines dates voilà qui apparaissent
alors merci de faire défiler tout ça mon
cher loïc c'est adorable vous avez à
lire dans la description venez me voir
sur scène c'est jamais la même chose
bientôt la tournée chez vous avec la v2
qui déjà lancé les écrans géants tout ça
c'est très cool abonnez vous à cette
chaîne likez mellick et pas que cette
vidéo leakée les gens vous aiment
à très bientôt ciao